les néolibéraux ont paniqué au sujet de leur précieux équilibre.
« Si vous augmentez le prix du travail, ont-ils averti,
les entreprises en acquerront moins.
Des milliers de travailleurs perdront leur emploi.
Les restaurants fermeront. »
Sauf que ...
ce n'a pas été le cas.
Le taux de chômage a considérablement chuté.
L'industrie de la restauration a connu un essor à Seattle.
Pourquoi ?
Car il n'y a pas d'équilibre.
Car augmenter les salaires ne tue pas les emplois, mais les crée.
Car, par exemple,
quand les propriétaires de restaurant doivent payer assez leurs travailleurs
pour qu'ils puissent se permettre de manger au restaurant,
l'industrie de la restauration ne diminue pas,
elle augmente, évidemment.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Le second postulat est
que le prix d'une chose équivaut toujours à sa valeur,
ce qui signifie que si vous gagnez 50 000 dollars par an
et que je gagne 50 millions de dollars par an,
c'est parce que je produis 1 000 fois plus de valeur que vous.
Maintenant,
cela ne vous surprendra pas d'apprendre
que c'est un postulat très réconfortant
si vous êtes un PDG qui se paye 50 millions de dollars par an
mais paye des salaires de misère à ses employés.
S'il vous plaît, croyez quelqu'un qui a dirigé des dizaines d'entreprises :
c'est n'importe quoi.
Les gens ne sont pas payés ce qu'ils valent.
Ils sont payés ce qu'ils ont le pouvoir de négocier
et la part décroissante des salaires dans le PIB
n'est pas due au fait que les travailleurs sont devenus moins productifs
mais parce que les employeurs sont devenus plus puissants.
Et --
(Applaudissements)
En prétendant que l'énorme déséquilibre des pouvoirs
entre le capital et la main-d’œuvre
n'existe pas,
la théorie économique néolibérale est devenue
une forme de racket.
Le troisième postulat, et de loin le plus pernicieux,
est un modèle comportemental
qui décrit les êtres humains comme étant « l'homo œconomicus »,
ce qui signifie que nous sommes tous parfaitement égoïstes,
parfaitement rationnels
et cherchons impitoyablement à maximiser notre satisfaction.
Mais demandez-vous :
est-il possible que, toute votre vie, à chaque fois que vous avez fait
quelque chose de gentil pour quelqu'un d'autre,
vous ne faisiez que maximiser votre propre utilité ?
Est-il plausible que quand un soldat saute sur une grenade
pour défendre d'autres soldats,
il ne fasse que promouvoir ses intérêts personnels ?
Si vous pensez que c'est dingue,
contraire à toute intuition morale raisonnable,
c'est parce que ça l'est
et, d'après les dernières découvertes scientifiques, c'est faux.
Mais c'est ce modèle comportemental
qui est au cœur froid et cruel de l'économie néolibérale
et c'est aussi moralement corrosif
que c'est scientifiquement erroné,
car si nous acceptons
que les humains sont fondamentalement égoïstes
puis que nous regardons dans le monde
toute la prospérité sans équivoque qui s'y trouve,
alors il s'ensuit logiquement,
alors cela doit être vrai par définition
que des milliards d'actes égoïstes
se transsubstantient en prospérité et en bien commun.
Si les humains ne sont que des maximisateurs égoïstes,
alors l'égoïsme est la cause de notre prospérité.
Selon cette logique,
la cupidité est une bonne chose,
augmenter les inégalités est efficace
et le seul but d'une entreprise
est d'enrichir les actionnaires,
car autrement cela ralentirait la croissance économique
et nuirait à l'économie dans son ensemble.
C'est cet évangile d'égoïsme
qui constitue le socle idéologique de l'économie néolibérale,
une façon de penser qui a produit des politiques économiques
qui nous ont permis, à moi et à mes riches camarades du premier pourcent,
de nous emparer de presque tous les bénéfices de la croissance
au cours des 40 dernières années.
Mais,
si au lieu de cela,
nous acceptons les dernières recherches empiriques,
la vraie science, qui décrit correctement les êtres humains
comme étant des créatures hautement coopératives,
réciproques
et intuitivement morales,
alors il s'ensuit logiquement
que ce doit être la coopération,
et non pas l'égoïsme,
qui soit la cause de notre prospérité
et ce n'est pas notre intérêt personnel,
mais notre inhérente réciprocité,
qui est le super-pouvoir économique de l'humanité.
Au cœur de cette nouvelle économie,
il y a une histoire à notre sujet
qui nous donne la permission d'être la meilleure version de nous-mêmes
et, contrairement à l'ancienne économie,
c'est une histoire qui est vertueuse
et qui a également la vertu d'être vraie.
Maintenant,
je veux souligner que cette nouvelle économie,
je ne l'ai pas personnellement imaginée ou inventée.
Ses théories et modèles sont développés et redéfinis
dans des universités à travers le monde,
s'appuyant sur certaines des meilleures recherches en économie,
les théories de la complexité et de l'évolution,
la psychologie, l'anthropologie et d'autres disciplines.
Même si cette nouvelle économie n'a pas encore son propre manuel
ou un nom communément accepté,
dans les grandes lignes,
son explication de l'origine de la prospérité est comme suit.
Le capitalisme de marché est un système évolutionnaire
où la prospérité émerge
via une boucle de rétroaction positive
entre une innovation croissante
et une demande croissante des consommateurs.
L'innovation est le processus via lequel nous résolvons les problèmes humains,
la demande des consommateurs est le mécanisme via lequel
le marché sélectionne des innovations utiles
et, en résolvant plus de problèmes, nous devenons plus prospères.
Mais en devenant plus prospères,
nos problèmes et solutions
deviennent plus complexes
et cette complexité technique croissante
nécessite des niveaux toujours plus élevés de coopération sociale et économique
afin de produire les produits plus spécialisés
qui définissent une économie moderne.
L'ancienne économie est correcte, bien sûr,
la concurrence joue un rôle crucial dans le fonctionnement des marchés,
mais ce qu'elle ne voit pas,
c'est que c'est majoritairement
une concurrence entre groupes très collaboratifs --
une concurrence entre entreprises, entre réseaux d'entreprises,
entre nations --
et quiconque a déjà dirigé une affaire fructueuse sait
que créer une équipe coopérative en incluant les talents de tout le monde
est presque toujours une meilleure stratégie
qu'une bande d'imbéciles égoïstes.
Comment laisser le néolibéralisme derrière nous
et créer une société plus durable, plus prospère
et plus équitable ?
La nouvelle économie suggère cinq règles empiriques.
Un : les économies fructueuses ne sont pas des jungles mais des jardins,
c'est-à-dire que les marchés,
comme les jardins, doivent être entretenus,
que le marché est la technologie sociale la plus importante jamais inventée
pour résoudre les problèmes humains
mais sans contraintes liées aux normes sociales
ou à la réglementation démocratique,
les marchés créent inévitablement plus de problèmes qu'ils n'en résolvent.
Le changement climatique,
la grande crise financière de 2008
sont deux exemples frappants.
La deuxième règle est
que l'inclusion entraîne de la croissance économique.
L'idée néolibérale selon laquelle
l'inclusion est un luxe fantaisiste
à s'accorder si et quand nous avons de la croissance
est fausse et à contre-courant.
L'économie, ce sont les gens.
Inclure plus de gens de plus de façons
est ce qui cause la croissance économique dans les économies de marché.
Le troisième principe
est que l'objet de l'entreprise n'est pas seulement d'enrichir les actionnaires.
La plus grande arnaque dans la vie économique contemporaine
est l'idée néolibérale selon laquelle le seul objet de l'entreprise
et la seule responsabilité des dirigeants
est de s'enrichir et d'enrichir les actionnaires.
La nouvelle économie doit et peut insister
que l'objet de l'entreprise
est d'améliorer le bien-être de toutes les parties prenantes :
les clients, les travailleurs,
la communauté et les actionnaires.
Quatrième règle :
l'avidité n'est pas une bonne chose.
Être rapace ne fait pas de vous un capitaliste,
cela fait de vous un sociopathe.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Dans une économie aussi dépendante de la coopération que la nôtre,
la sociopathie est aussi mauvaise pour les affaires que pour la société.
Cinquièmement et finalement :
contrairement aux lois de la physique,
les lois de l'économie sont un choix.
La théorie économique néolibérale
s'est vendue à vous comme étant un loi naturelle immuable
alors que ce sont des normes sociales et des récits construits
reposant sur de la pseudo-science.
Si nous voulons vraiment d'une économie plus équitable,
plus prospère et plus durable,
si nous voulons des démocraties et une société civile
hautement fonctionnelles,
il nous faut une nouvelle économie.
Voici la bonne nouvelle :
si nous voulons d'une nouvelle économie,
nous n'avons qu'à choisir d'en avoir une nouvelle.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Modératrice : Nick, je suis sûre que l'on vous le demande souvent.
Si vous êtes si mécontent du système économique,
pourquoi ne pas donner tout votre argent et rejoindre les 99% ?
Nick Hanauer : Ouais, non, oui, bien.
On l'entend beaucoup.
« Si les impôts vous importent, pourquoi ne pas payer plus
et si les salaires vous importent, pourquoi ne pas payer plus ? »
Je le pourrais.
Le problème est
que cela ne fait pas de grande différence
et j'ai découvert une stratégie
qui fonctionne 100 000 fois mieux --
Modératrice : D'accord.
NH : consistant à utiliser mon argent pour créer des récits et passer des lois
nécessitant que tous les autres riches
payent des impôts et payent mieux leurs travailleurs.
(Applaudissements)
Par exemple,
le salaire minimum de 15 dollars que nous avons initié
a affecté 30 millions de travailleurs.
Cela fonctionne mieux.
Modératrice : Super.
Si vous changez d'avis, nous sommes preneurs.
NH : Oh. Merci. Modératrice : Merci beaucoup.